Vous êtes 8 millions d'abonnés à ma chaîne Youtube
Merci beaucoup
C'est la fête
Pour vous remercier je vais faire comme d'habitude une petite vidéo
Alors, j'ai déjà répondu à vos questions, je vous ai déjà livré des anecdotes sur moi-même
Maintenant, je vais vous présenter des objets chelous trouvés sur Internet
Alors comme je suis pas le premier sur Youtube à avoir eu cette idée
Certains d'entres vous vont dire
"Ouais mais c'est pas très original"
Ouais mais c'est pas très original
*Bruit de chargement*
*Tir*
c'est parti. Alors je vais pas vous le cacher, la plupart des objets que j'ai trouvé
viennent du Japon. Parce que là-bas on met de la drogue dure
dans les biberons des nouveaux-nés. C'est en tout cas la seule explication que j'ai trouvé à ce jour
on va commencer avec des petits objets. vous savez
j'adore le poisson il fallait donc que je me
procure une trousse
en forme de maquereau. Cadavre de maquereau puisqu'on voit bien ses yeux totalement
décédés. Petit détail sympathique
qui va faire fureur dans les écoles
j'en doute pas. A l'intérieur il y a
bien sûr les entrailles du maquereau
qui
a envie de voir ça à tous les jours ? Les
écrans des smartphones sont de plus en
plus grands. Un mec s'est dit mon pouce est trop petit pour ses écrans je vais donc
créer une extension de pouce.
Exceptionnel parce que déjà ça marche
une fois
sur trois. En plus ils ont mis un
petit bout de plastique noir pour que ce
soit tactile. Le truc est tellement mal
fait qu'il pouvait pas faire le pouce
tactile. Il fallait rajouter un truc
dégueulasse. Nous sommes en 2015
ils ont ressorti le Furby
Chewbacca *bruit du Furby*
D'accord. Il fait un bruit de Chewbacca genre- *bruit du Furby*
Ta gueule. Il fait un bruit de chewbacca comme une sorte de porte qui s'ouvre
Je sais qu'il danse aussi quand on fait de la musique.
*beatbox*
*beatbox*Au revoir Furbacca. Tape-là. C'est vrai. Il a pas de bras.
On arrive dans la partie humiliante avec cet objet qui est une sorte
de bouche. Je pense que c'est pour muscler le
visage
bonjour
c'est extrêmement bi-
bizarre. Ca nique les gencives. Les femmes se mettent ça pour être plus belles
Faudra faire attention quand même, penser à l'enlever *bruit de sonnette*
bonsoir mon chéri
on arrive à un moment que j'aime beaucoup dans cette vidéo c'est le moment
musical
avec cet objet qui fait de la percussion, ça fonctionne sur un
principe très très étrange quand on
appuie sur un des joysticks
ça fait des percussions. Comme vous savez je fais un peu de batterie donc je vais faire une heure et demie de
ça. C'est parti
il y a même carrément un petit crochet pour
l'accrocher autour du cou. J'irai pas jusque-là
alors je sais pas comment
décrire cet objet c'est une note de
musique avec des touches
et un bouche quand on appuie dessus ça fait du bruit
bref une démonstration sera plus parlante
rock mode
yeah
mais vous savez ce que ça veut dire ?
*musique*
maintenant un de mes objets préférés vous connaissez le bras de fer chinois avec des pouces c'est nul
pourquoi pas faire un bras de fer chinois
avec des robots c'est le premier qui arrive à faire sauter l'autre qui a gagné
tout de suite
une démonstration
FIGHT
oh tu m'as pas vu venir
oh putain
ok round 2 round 2
ça se joue en 3 rounds
Round 2 FIGHT
le mien est fort parce qu'il a des
poings alors que le tien il a des vieilles paumes
pour faire des high-five c'est cool
ok calmes-toi, calmes-toi, calmes-toi
Round 3 FIGHT
mais noon, en one-shot. J'hallucine
j'avais mis un peu de glue sur le tien ça me fout la rage de faire venir ça du Japon tu sais de l'avoir
sélectionné. on dit que celui qui gagne celui-là
celui-là qui gagne celui-là il a tout gagné
il a même gagné les parties sur les autres jeux
CHALLENGE ACCEPTED
parfaite égalité
du coup maintenant que j'ai fait venir cet objet du japon je propose qu'on fasse juste un bras de fer chinois
un vrai ? d'accord. Ils ont percé ceux qui ont créé ça
par contre j'aimerai tricher prendre le pouce pour le téléphone
merci voilà parce qu'on trouve une autre utilité à chaque objet
1 2 3 bras de fer chinois
très très nul en fait c'est pire que tout. ouais mais regarde
c'est un leurre c'est un putain de leurre. Revenons un instant sur la beauté, la bouche
c'était bien. mais là c'est un masque que les japonaises se mettent sur la gueule c'est pour j'imagine
tirer les rides
et ce que j'aime bien
c'est que en fait ça fait un visage
de grand brûlé. il y a un petit côté
Hannibal Lecter
je pense que c'est nickel c'est bon
à quel moment je dois être séduisant après ça ? S'il vous plaît ne faites pas
de screenshot de ça, je suis respectueux
envers vous, faites de même s'il vous
plaît. et si je le mets à l'envers ?
c'est ignoble j'ai envie de les percer
je l'ai pété et voilà c'est cassé
on a tous envie de s'allonger sur les
jambes d'une femme qui nous passe sa main dans les
cheveux
alors la main je l'ai pas mais par contre les jambes je les ai
c'est un oreiller de jambes de femme qui
fonctionne de cette manière là
voilà comme ça franchement c'est pas
trop mal y a juste quand on retourne
on lui a pété les chevilles. on voit un bout de culotte également s'il vous plaît les pervers
personne n'est pervers ici
on dirait un petit peu qu'elle a des chicken wings à la place des pieds
parfois il fait chaud et on aimerait avoir un peu plus froid
il faut savoir que c'est du L
c'est du L japonais
cette veste ressemble à toutes les autres vestes
si ce n'est qu'elle est beaucoup plus moche
à un détail près il fait chaud
aujourd'hui
j'aimerais bien avoir un peu plus froid
deux ventilateurs qui soufflent dans
la veste n'hésitez pas à me dire ce
que vous pensez de cette invention dans les commentaires je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de penser au mec qui a eu
l'idée de cette veste. écoutes
j'ai créé une veste quand on a trop chaud comme ça paf elle balance de l'air
mais si t'as trop chaud tu te mets en t-shirt en fait. Tu mets où les ventilateurs ? je
comprends pas ton concept de t-shirt je comprends pas. alors là j'ai
un autre vêtement. voilà un petit gilet sympa en lycra et- Quoi ?
une situation périlleuse ? j'ai toujours rêvé d'être un ninja
par contre c'est dommage parce que
ça tient chaud
c'est beaucoup mieux. on va revenir à la beauté avec un masque qui
empêche d'avoir les yeux qui tombent mais qui a aussi une particularité il te fait aussi
ressembler à un super-héros je suis le
premier super-héros ninja qui n'a pas
chaud, qui n'a pas les yeux qui tombent et ça
c'est important. Oh non !
un moustique il me faudrait une
moustiquaire
juste pour moi
si seulement ça existait
une moustiquaire
mono-personnelle
je ressemble
à une capote géante
je pense que c'est plus judicieux de
s'arrêter là
je suis sortie de ma capote je voulais
profondément vous remercier pour les
8 millions d'abonnés oui ça c'est un
accoutrement normal pour remercier les gens
parce que Youtube c'est toute
ma vie, faire plaisir aux
internautes d'essayer de vous faire rire
de montrer aussi des petits trucs
qui font un peu plus rêver comme
mes courts métrages d'ailleurs je bosse
sur un prochain court métrage
qui arriverait dans pas très
très très très longtemps ça me fait
vibrer de créer ça pour vous et
encore merci d'être aussi nombreux
à me suivre merci beaucoup je vous dis à
très vite dans une prochaine vidéo
j'ai envie de dire abonnez-vous mais  8 millions déjà
c'est exceptionnel